au
plus fort donc baisse des renforts sont
entrés encore de pro berger verseur vers
la ville de bessèges ce sont 500
pompiers qui sont sur le terrain cette
nuit leur mission est de tenir le feu
sur ses flancs ou gauche et six endroits
qui sont toujours pas stabilisée on a
des reprises de feu et il faut
absolument contenir ce feu mais
uniquement par des moyens terrestres
actuellement dans le loyer on a un fils
qui a parcouru environ 600 hectares à
l'heure actuelle on en continu la montée
en puissance des moyens parce que ça
change des secteurs qui sont très très
difficile difficilement accessible
et donc il faut que l'on fasse un très
beau voyage plutôt tourner périmètre du
feu pour pouvoir le fixe et définitive